ahora ya sabemos cuánto tiempo estará el
objeto en el aire y estamos listos para
averiguar qué tan lejos llegará ahora
llegaremos a la fórmula central en todas
las cinemáticas o en los problemas de
movimiento de proyectiles o mecánicos y
esta es distancia igual la rapidez por
el tiempo ahora estamos hablando de la
distancia horizontal nuestra distancia
va a ser igual a que el elemento de
nuestro componente horizontal pues
nuestra rapidez horizontal esta es
nuestra parte de la distancia así que el
componente horizontal de nuestra
velocidad o la magnitud del componente
horizontal de la velocidad pues lo
encontramos en el vídeo anterior es ese
porque seno de teta vamos a escribirlo
aquí abajo nuestra rapidez es s por
coseno de teta y qué tanto tiempo
estaremos en el aire o estará el objeto
en el aire bueno tendremos esta rapidez
tanto tiempo como esté el objeto en el
aire y este tiempo lo encontramos en el
vídeo anterior vamos a estar en el aire
ese tiempo 2 por s por 0 dt está entre g
así que nuestro tiempo va a ser 2 por
ese por seno detecta
/ g así que la distancia que viajará el
objeto es bastante directa rapidez por
tiempo y podemos poner al frente todas
nuestras constantes para que quede mucho
más claro que es una función de theta
podemos encontrar que la distancia
recorrida como una función de theta va a
ser igual a estos elementos constantes 2
por s cuadrada / g aquí están todos mis
elementos constantes por el consumo de
teta por el seno de teta
y aquí tenemos una función general si
ustedes me dan el ángulo con el que voy
a lanzar algún objeto y si también me
dan la magnitud de su velocidad y bueno
si también me dicen la aceleración de la
gravedad en caso de que estemos en algún
otro planeta quién sabe yo podré
decirles exactamente cuál es la
distancia horizontal que va a recorrer
este objeto